it's stimulating mind-expanding safer to
use that alcohol it's the in thing the
jet generation as the United States
enters its 72nd year of marijuana
prohibition it's time to legalize pot
once and for all for at least three good
reasons a 2005 cost-benefit analysis by
Harvard economist Jeffrey Myron found
the taxing regulating pot like alcohol
would bring in at least six billion
dollars a year in taxes and reduce
direct law enforcement cost by almost 8
billion dollars annually those figures
would only be higher in today's dollars
despite the lousy economy by various
measures marijuana is already the top
cash crop in a dozen states why not
bring its cultivation and sales out into
the open
last year a Zogby poll found that 52% of
Americans agreed that it makes sense to
tax and regulate marijuana a Field Poll
of California residents who will vote on
a ballot initiative to legalize pot in
the fall found that 56% thought we'd
should be freed other polls show
historic levels of support for
legalization of pot given such grown
sentiments it's only a matter of when
not if pot becomes legal
never mind up by virtually any measure
marijuana is safer and less disruptive
than booze pot prohibition in the 1930s
was born out of hysteria of reefer
madness every bit as misguided and
destructive as the noble experiment in
alcohol prohibition the war on pot has
been a failure by every measure a waster
of police time a creator of black-market
crime and violence and a destroyer of
lives especially among
disproportionately poor and minority
citizens who are more likely to be
thrown in jail we own our own bodies and
should be free to eat smoke and drink
what we want and to take responsibility
for our actions whether we're straight
or whether we're stoned what I do
believe is that we need to rethink for
reason TV I'm Nicolas me
you